all right good morning everyone uh
welcome to the third session of uh
our workshop i'm uh very glad to
introduce our first speaker for the
morning uh nicolas garcia trios coming
from university of wisconsin-madison who
will be talking about an analytical and
geometrical
perspective on adversarial learning
okay thank you then and thank you uh to
the organizers to elena philippe and
everybody else i mean not only for the
workshop but also for the long term
program
so yeah so of course from the title you
can already imagine i'm not going to
talk about sampling and in fact i may
not even
talk about samples at all at any point
in the talk but i still think that this
is a topic that may be of interest to
many of you
and it's going to be also
a perspective that is i would say quite
different from the one that people
usually take when they think about
adversarial learning
so
okay so then at a high level what i'm
going to try to connect is two types of
problems one of them is going to be an
adversarial training or learning problem
and another problem will be
regularization and we're going to be
talking about those two
all along the talk
okay so then just to fix some ideas
when i talk about adversarial training
or learning
uh what i mean is a concrete
mathematical problem like the one that
you see over there so there are a few
things here so we have first of all it's
a min max problem
and then there are a bunch of
elements in this in this program and
this problem so the first thing is we
have a distribution mu
that you can see over here this you can
think of your actual distribution your
actual data distribution this is what
you have
and then this is a distribution on
so this is distribution
on
let's say
a variable z that typically we're going
to imagine our pairs x comma y
and typically we're going to imagine
that x is an element in our d and that y
is either a real number or say a label
uh say zero or one for example okay so
this is uh what we're thinking about
when we think about mu
um what other elements we have in this
problem we have this idea of theta okay
so theta here describes the parameter of
a statistical model and this could be
the parameters of a neural network it
could be the parameters of a linear
regression or it could also be a
nonparametric uh
binary classifier so for example just a
set okay and in fact this is going to be
the case that we will consider later
so this is just parameter
of a
statistical
model
okay another thing that we have over
here is a loss function
and of course depending on uh the
problem we're interested in the loss
function will be different okay so you
could think of it as maybe it's a square
loss or it's a zero one loss but it's
something that tells me like if i have
an input vector or an or a data point z
and i have my model uh theta then i want
to know uh what is the error associated
to you know that uh specific model when
uh predicting for example what happens
between x and y
and then finally the uh the last
ingredient that we have over here is
this
object d over here
which
is
essentially is a way to measure
perturbations to your data okay so
uh essentially what we want to do is to
say we want to find the best possible
model but not just associated to our
fixed data distribution but we want to
do it uh robustly so that even if we uh
add perturbations to our data still our
inference is uh meaningful okay so
that's that's where the min max problem
comes comes in okay so and then of
course this d could be a vaster same
distance or a kl divergence something of
that sort something that measures the
differences between the distributions
okay so those are the ingredients
of adversarial training
and by the way so the distinction maybe
between training and learning is what is
the emphasis i suppose and training for
me is i'm
i'm interested in the finding the theta
i don't really care about how to
generate the adverse size that's that's
something important
um okay now let's look at the other
problem the other problem is regularized
risk minimization so we see this type of
problem in many different fields right
so in classical statistics
uh
when we think about
uh reach regression or lasso regression
we're thinking about a regularized
minimization problem
uh in inverse problems right in inverse
problems
when uh we think about
of regularization what we're thinking
about is solving a problem that looks
like this
and uh and also
in uh something called graph based
learning
so if for example we are
trying to
do something like trend filtering or
something of that sort we're also uh
working with a setting where we have a
loss function plus some regularization
term
okay so this is a this is something that
is
rich in terms of uh
theory
but perhaps it's not as
statistically intuitive as the first
type of problem the adversarial problem
because there you really see
okay i want to be robust to data
perturbations
whereas when you write it the problem
like this regularized race minimization
is not really clear
you're robust to what okay so it's a
little bit more theoretical we like it
it has connections to many different
areas in applied math etc etc but let's
say it's a little bit less intuitive as
the other one
and as i was saying the purpose of this
talk is to connect these two
um now so then really the question here
is
what is the relationship between
adversarial training and regularization
and a quick answer is going to be we're
going to look at the some of the
literature and we're going to find that
there is sometimes a very direct
connection when i say the very direct
connection is that you can find an
equivalence between these two problems
in some settings okay so let's just look
at one of those settings where these two
things are equivalent okay so the
setting is uh that of regression so
imagine that
my parameter set in this case is just rd
so it's going to represent the parameter
in a linear regression problem
the loss function is something simple
like square loss
like what we have here
um the distance between distributions is
going to take
this specific form okay so it's going to
be
a one optimal transport problem where
the cost is determined by
uh
a p norm in euclidean space okay so now
there is a little subtlety in the way
that this cost is defined
and um i just want to go over this uh
construction over here so the way that
i'm going to measure how far
perturbation is from the from the
original distribution move is by solving
an optimal transfer problem as i said
before but the important thing is what's
the type of cost function that i'm
considering
and the idea is intuitively what is
happening is i'm going to uh charge cos
infinity if the adversary tries to swap
labels okay so this is kind of what what
people do in practice when people doing
practice and construct adversaries
you know this is a setting i suppose but
not necessarily they change labels they
just change the x coordinate but they
don't necessarily change the labels so
if we want to formalize that we can say
okay fine you can consider perturbations
as long as the adversary is not changing
uh labels otherwise the the adversary
would be charged plus infinity
and then this uh norm here is just the p
norm the the p the alpine little lp norm
uh of the vector x minus uh x tilde
um okay so that's that's the uh
that's the d in that case and so what
turns out is that uh the original
problem
uh so the the adversarial problem so
this infinium
over theta in theta
uh and then we take the supremum
over mu tilde
such the d
you till the with the cost uh p here so
this uh i'm just going to highlight that
there is a p over there mutilda mu less
than epsilon
uh so this thing uh you know can then we
have the expectation of
x tilde y tilde sample from u tilde
uh and then the loss
so here let's say x z tilde
and then theta
so in this specific setting
this thing is equal
so it's not approximately liquid it's
equal for all epsilon to a problem that
looks like this
okay so it's just a minimization over
theta and it should have more or less
the structure of regularized risk
minimization so in this case it looks
like this
there is a square root
and now we have data sampled from the
original distribution mu not to not or
not
it's not computed with respect to
perturbations
um and then we have uh the loss function
maybe i should make this square bigger
and then we have square root of epsilon
times the q norm
of theta and there is a square over here
okay and so then there is a relationship
between the p that you chose for your
cost how you're charging the adversary
and
the q that appears here that appears as
a regularization uh
for your parameter theta okay so here
one p plus one over q is equal to one
and i guess this is somehow expected
just because there is some duality
happening there
so this is an equality you can also see
that depending on what is the
adversarial budget how much are you
allowing the adversary to change
the move
that appears here as the parameter for
irregularization and this would be
exactly like what i showed earlier in
general for regular for regularized risk
minimization except that maybe there is
a square root here that is a little bit
annoying but it's it's what comes out um
but morally speaking you still have just
a problem where you don't have any
adversaries there's no supremium
involved and this has the uh form and
the flavor of a regular s-risk
minimization and this is unequivocal
and how do you prove something like this
it's in fact not so difficult
you just have to well first of all
recognize that when you work with this
type of metric between distributions in
reality this
problem over here for a fixed data in
reality it's a linear program if you
write it in terms of couplings and if
you just place your duality and you know
do your computations you can recover uh
this problem over here
not only the minimum values are the same
also the minimizers are the same so in
reality these two problems are
equivalent
and this is something that is has been
discussed in in different papers for
quite a while now but at least there are
like three papers that i'm familiar with
that kind of like reunite this kind of
type of knowledge and not only for this
type of problem but extended versions of
things like this
okay so that's the setting that that uh
where we have a direct uh equivalence
just one comment here notice that when q
is equal to one
this
model that we have over here is what is
called the square root lasso model that
became popular about 10 years ago
okay now
this is one setting yes
i believe that it is for every theta but
uh but i may be i mean i may be wrong
but i believe it is for every theta uh
if not then okay the magic of how these
things are swapped and would make it
work for the minimizers but i do believe
that it's for everything
you would have something similar but i i
guess this is one model that people like
because i mean when people construct the
adversaries they typically just perturb
the the data but they don't change the
label but you could also imagine
changing the label you just have to tell
me how you're going to penalize that if
if at all
you would probably get something similar
oh sorry yes thank you yes
sorry
uh okay so the question that shane was
asking is what happens if i change the
cost over here so if i essentially allow
the adversary to change labels if some
of this duality would you know would uh
be true well
yes again probably yes something like
this would be would be okay but then you
would have to tell me exactly how how
you're dealing with changing labels but
but something along this line should
should work
for sure
um
i mean and of course like what works
nicely in this case is that there's a
lot of nice properties of this loss
function so for example this function is
convex in the in the data so those types
of things play a role in being able to
determine like an exact equivalence for
example
uh okay now uh
one thing that is kind of clear is okay
so this is a very restricted model
and other times it may be more difficult
more challenging to identify a
connection between adversarial training
and regularization so uh now whatever we
can say about that relationship will
depend on the specific set and this is
kind of like an obvious fact i know but
the specific set of of course guides the
type of math and math tools that you
you're supposed to use to search for
that uh equivalence or that relationship
and also it also guides the types of
questions that you can ask so every
model has its own questions every model
has also its tools
so uh today's talk is gonna be based on
uh three papers that kind of uh you know
i've been thinking about this for
around a year and in these three papers
i'm trying to explore this question what
is the connection of adversarial
learning and regularization in settings
that are not like the ones that i
described earlier so different settings
and
of course
because the time is short i will not be
able to talk about everything and i will
have to skip
this one with uh camilo garciatrius but
uh i will be able to discuss uh this one
over here and uh something that
uh you know we've been discussing with
liam bunger so this is one of the nice
things about the simon's institute that
we can interact with so fabulous
collaborators and get some really nice
stuff done so i will talk a little bit
about the stuff that we've been doing uh
here
okay so what is the setup the setup is
our parameters theta in this case are
going to be subsets of rd okay so from
now on i'm going to forget about theta
because i don't want to give you the
impression that this is parametric i'm
just going to give you the impression
that these are sets okay so i'm going to
be looking for subsets of rd
um
the data is going to be pairs x y so x
is a vector in rd and y is a number
uh 0 1. so it's it's really like binary
classification
and here what you have to imagine is
that to define a binary classifier what
you have to tell me is in what region in
space you're going to assign the label
one and of course in the complement
you're gonna assign the labels here so
when i talk about a i really mean about
a binary classifier okay
um the uh
distance between distributions is going
to have this form
and just to make clear what do i mean by
this so
i need to first define a metric between
pairs x y and x still the y tilde and
i'm going to define it here as
um
is going to be simply the distance
between x and x tilde
if y is equal to y tilde this is like
before and it's going to be plus
infinity if y is different from y tilde
in other words i'm still under the
assumption that the adversary cannot
change labels only can perturb
data points
um
this d over here
for the first uh things that i will
discuss think about it as euclidean
distance but later you can think about
it as absolutely anything else that you
want and i'll make comments about that
in a moment and then once you have this
distance then the double infinity uh
here this is the infinity optimal
transport distance between mu and
mutilda for that cost uh that i just
defined here for this d over here so i'm
just defining a new metric in the space
x cross y and i'm considering the
infinity values and distance with
respect to that metric
uh between uh measures mu and tilde okay
so this w that w infinity would look
like so if i'm computing mu and mutilda
this would be like the infimum overall
couplings between mu and mutilda
and then here i would have uh a supremum
over points
c comma z tilde in the support
of pi
and of course the supremum is i'm taking
is over dc
c tilde
okay so okay okay so this is a little
bit
cramped over there but uh i hope that uh
the idea is is clear okay so it's the
infinity distance with respect to this
to this metric
uh okay and then the loss function
finally is just going to be zero one
loss so if i am predicting correctly the
the label y
i don't pay anything
uh and if i am predicting incorrectly
the label y then i am going to
pay uh one unit okay
so all right so this is the this is the
setup
and
one thing that is interesting here is
that we can say okay we can
you know consider them this problem this
is our adversarial problem
more explicitly written and i can give a
name to
this guy over here so this is like a new
functional let me call it l epsilon that
depends on a set a so you give me a set
a and i can compute this this value for
it
and there is an observation the
observation is that when epsilon is
equal to zero if you consider
the solution
to
that problem
this is
something that we all know so this is
perhaps the lecture one in statistical
learning this is the base classifier
so this is the set
of points
in rd
such that and i'm going to write it like
this
x w101x greater than w zero or zero
x
and here implicitly i'm assuming that
you know for i'm gonna tell you in a
second what is w one over one but i'm
assuming that i'm in a nice case i'm not
looking at empirical distributions here
i'm just looking at my mu is something
that has densities etcetera etcetera so
just to be more precise
when i talk about w0 what i mean is
really the proportion of labels that are
zero in my distribution my data
distribution when i'm talking about w1
is the same thing but for label one
we're not talking about row zero that's
the conditional distribution of x given
that y is equal to zero and when i'm
talking about row one this is the
conditional distribution of x given that
y is equal to one
um row is the same thing but uh the
whole the whole distribution over x okay
so that's that's the that's the problem
that we have there
and now i'm going to ask a question
suppose that i start with the base
classifier
and i'm going to say look i want to
infinitesimally change that boundary so
that as epsilon grows
i would like to keep track of what are
the global solutions of all
parameterized problems
the parameters in this case by epsilon
so every epsilon gives me an
optimization problem and i just want to
track solutions starting with the base
classifier okay so that's the question
and why i'm asking this question there
are two reasons first
because this is something that people do
in statistics for example when you talk
about optimization paths in lasso that's
exactly what people do you're tracking
solutions to the lasso problem as you
change the regularization parameter
now
here i would like to do something else
but i'm not doing regularization i'm
doing adversarial learning so it's a
little bit different
first thing the second motivation is
because i am trying to capture what is
the regularization effect of this
adversarial learning problem so if i
have my base classifier and i can tell
you how infinite testimony is going to
change that tells me something about in
what way the presence of the adversary
is regularizing the problem okay so
that's really what i'm what i'm
interested in so i'm interested in you
know so try to construct a solution
maybe at least for a small time now you
have to think about the budget the other
sale budget as time and for every
epsilon i want to construct
a set say a absolute
and at time 0
i want this to be the base classifier a0
star let's say
and uh of course what i want is that
a epsilon is
uh the
arc mean or is an arc mean
over o a of this functional l epsilon a
okay does that doesn't make sense
so this is my goal okay
now
okay let's try to explore this question
there are two motivations again and
let's see where this where this takes us
now it is convenient to go back to our
function okay so to see you know what's
happening what are we really computing
when we compute this expression over
here
and what it turns out is that actually
this problem can be rewritten in a
convenient way
as an expectation
over x y with respect to mu this is the
fixed distribution
but then uh the supremum you can move
inside okay so you can write this as
supremum now over perturbations that are
uh have to be within a a distance
epsilon from x and i'm still computing l
uh here x tilde comma y uh and then my
set a over here okay remember that so
here the reason why there is no y tilde
is because remember the adversary cannot
change labels so if it's okay to change
x to x tilde but the y has to be the
same so that's why i don't have to put a
y tilde over there
okay so that's that's that's something
that one can check that those two those
two things are equivalent for every a
and now uh
there is a deal index yes
thanks
and now what we do is okay let's just
try to understand what's happening over
here depending on what where x is
located so let's take for example this
set a that i have over there
and then what you can notice is that if
you take a point x
that is away
so it's it's in a but it's away from the
boundary more than distance epsilon so
it doesn't really matter what the
adversary does it is always going to
take you to a point that is in a so it's
not going to change the label so it
doesn't matter what what the adversary
does it's not going to change anything
so somehow the the contribution to the
to this expression
um in this region over here away from
the boundary inside the set is the same
thing as what you would get for the
usual base classifier or sorry the base
risk
or i guess a better term is this this
functional l0
similar story happens when you're
outside
away from the boundary nothing is going
to change
and the interesting stuff happens when
you are distance within distance epsilon
from uh the boundary what is going to
happen is that this adversary is super
powerful and essentially is always going
to be able to
make you make a mistake
if you are have a point x within
distance epsilon from the boundary so
from that observation it's not so
difficult to realize that this function
is the same thing as integration over
uh like a
a thick boundary of a so by the thick
boundary of a i you would just mean
this region over here
and here i would have rho x dx
so here there is no distinction whether
you were label zero label one because
the adversary can always guarantee that
you're going to make a mistake so here
you just have to wait what is the
likelihood that i i i have a point x in
that region
and then in the other regions
you would have
something like this so this a minus
epsilon would be
a except the points that are within
distance epsilon from the boundary and
here you pay whenever you're
your actual label is the zero label
because it's that's the case when you
are making a mistake you if you're in a
you're predicting label one and so you
make a mistake if the label turns out to
be zero so that's why uh we weight
against w zero zero and then a similar
story uh outside with the complement of
a epsilon a epsilon would be a and the
uh the boundary uh the the epsilon
boundary of a
and in that in that region you would be
paying w1 row 1 dx okay so that would be
that would be the computation
so with this expression then you can
wonder okay so let's go back to these
questions of how can we track solutions
and so here is the first result
suppose that the base classifier this is
in one dimension first suppose that the
various classifier you can write it as a
union of intervals and this is
reasonable if you imagine that your
distributions have densities they will
be crossing only at finitely many points
and there are some regularity conditions
so it's it's fair to imagine that the
base classifier looks like this just a
union of intervals
and then there is some strict crossing
condition i'll explain in a moment what
i mean by that but as long as this
density satisfy this
then we can track solutions now tracking
solutions in this case would mean
how are the endpoints of these intervals
change how are they going to move okay
so uh
i'm going to then tell you what are
those equations so they would look like
this
so for example take right end points the
big case for me are right end points
they will be evolving
according to this ordinary differential
equation with
at epsilon zero they start at well the
location that you had for the uh base
classifier
um and then you would have a similar
similar ode for for the a case now
notice that these equations
i don't have a guarantee that they're
going to exist everywhere i mean this
this denominator here could go to zero
and i would be in trouble
um
uh
but some what the theorem says is that
at least for a small enough epsilon if i
track
uh if i solve this odes i have a
guarantee that i will have a solution to
the um
to the to the uh epsilon problem yes
so uh
w0 and w1 can you remind us what it is
is it the proportions of zeros and ones
like unconditionally on x right
unconditional index yes so in the
previous setup wasn't it supposed to
depend on epsilon when you actually
wrote the part that was like on epsilon
or not i mean is it because you're doing
expansion around zero i'm a bit confused
like
right so in the in the previous thing
when you integrated around a minus
epsilon and a epsilon complement yeah
so this one here this is a constant this
is these are constants
but okay
yeah so so those those those terms come
out uh naturally as just uh you know
are the proportions unconditional and x
and those are constants okay
all right
okay and then uh so there are similar
equations for for ak
and uh you know one one thing that i
wanted to mention about this uh oh maybe
maybe this crossing condition the
crossing condition is really that if you
if you plot w under 1 and w 0 0 whenever
they intersect the tangent should be
different that's kind of the only
condition that i'm that i'm asking so if
you have this
then you will be able to to solve this
ods and track global solutions
so just a few comments about how do i
how do we show this
so actually there is an interesting
connection between the adversary
learning problem in general not just for
1d and optimal transport in fact the the
adversarial problem can be written as
the dual of another
as an optimal transport problem
and so this actually gives a way to have
a certificate that if you have
candidates for global solutions to your
adversarial problem what you just have
to do is find a certificate and if you
you know find that certificate that
would show that you have global
optimality so this uh connection to
optimal transport has been explored
before at least in the case w0 equals w1
so in the balance case and in in our
work with ryan we also
describe what is the correct problem in
the case in the imbalance case so so
that principle can be used to check that
the candidate solutions are indeed
global solutions
now there is a problem with the 1d
setting and is that it doesn't really
reveal anything geometric we probably
haven't learned much i mean i showed you
those orders but there is nothing really
intuitive that we can get out of it
so um you can say then the question is
well what happens in indi greater than
one
and of course the answer is gonna be
well the you can expect the questions
are gonna get messier you can try to
write them and in fact we do at least
assuming that those solutions exist and
assuming that those solutions are
regular you can write them down formally
at least
and they're messy
but then at least we can try to say okay
at epsilon equals zero we can try to
answer the question how does the
boundary of a zero changes
infinitesimally so at least at the
beginning of i turn on the adversary
what's happening with the with the set
so um
essentially what i'm just what i'm
asking is so suppose that this is the
base classifier the ac or star
uh how should i
move
uh this boundary infinitesimally so i
i'm looking for a vector field that is
going to deform the boundary of this set
and i'm trying to identify what that
what what that vector field is
well it turns out that uh one can write
down what that vector field would be
so to track solutions you would have to
start modifying the base classifier in
this way so this is my vector v zero x
for example well i guess
i guess if i call this guy vc or x this
would be my my uh my vector field so at
that point infinitesimal is going to
start moving at that at that speed in
the normal direction
and what is important to notice is there
are two contributions really
one thing has to do with where is the
density getting smaller
that makes sense you want to push
things towards regions where there's not
too many data points and therefore the
adversary cannot attack you too much
and then there is a term and this is the
one that is more interesting that has to
do with curvature it has to do with
geometry the geometry of the of the
shape and in particular is mean
curvature
okay now uh this is what you get now
what i'm more interested in is to say uh
okay
but that same infinitesimal change is
what you would have obtained
if you were tracking solutions of a
different problem a problem that looks
like this
and now this looks more like
regularization i'm saying i have my
empirical risk or my risk and then i'm
penalizing the sets with something in
this case the perimeter
and what i'm saying is that again the
infinitesimal change of tracking
solutions to adversarial problems and
the
infinite decimal chain of tracking
solutions to this new problem now of
course i'm tracking solutions as i
change this regularization parameter
epsilon those two things would coincide
and okay so then what is perimeter
perimeter at least in this in this
setting is what we we think of perimeter
so it's basically you look at the
boundary of the set and you just measure
how big it is in this case is weighted
by the density row the density the
unconditional density row for for x
so okay so what what are we learning
from this uh thing first of all the
perimeter is connected to the
regularization induced induced by optim
uh by adversarial train okay so this is
what we're learning from from this
computation
but then the question is is there an
equivalence between r prime and
adversarial training so in other words
that for every epsilon this problem r
prime is equivalent to the adversarial
problem okay so that's that's the
question that we're now we're asking so
if they're related but only at epsilon
zero the question is are they related uh
afterwards
and of course you can imagine that the
answer is no
okay but there's something i think quite
nice that happens
and so i'm going to start doing
something
that is going to look a little bit silly
here but nonetheless i'll do it
so
this thing over here is the objective
function for the adversarial training
problem
and so i'm just going to do you know i'm
looking for the risk with the
distribution mu i want that to appear
and here we can do what we
mathematicians do all the time which is
add and subtract things and see what
what happens when when we do that
so i'm going to do that then so i'm
going to make something new up here so
i'm going to say okay so just take
c
sample from mu
and here you just have l
x comma y
a so that's the risk that i'm looking
for
i added it and i have to subtract it so
i still have z
blue
uh supremum
x tilde
b x
l
x tilde y tilde
or sorry no y tilde
comma a
minus
expectation c m
l x comma y
a okay so i just added and subtracted
i'm going to do something more and is
i'm going to divide and multiply by
epsilon
and i'm going to call this guy
perimeter epsilon a
okay so i'm gonna give that i'm gonna do
that
and i could say okay here is your
regularized prop and then i'm done and
you know i found an equivalence between
adversarial training and regularized
risk minimization but of course this
wouldn't be a satisfactory answer unless
we say what is this this object that i
defined here what are the properties
that it has okay
so uh
well first of all the notation is
suggestive it's a perimeter
and what that means is the following so
this is ongoing work with uh leon
um
well first of all the obvious that the
adversarial training problem is
equivalent to this regularization
problem
and now the properties so first of all
that for every a this functional so you
give me a set i compute this functional
you get something positive that's very
easy to see because this soup over here
is always greater than this thing over
here so you always have positivity or no
negativity
and the key property though is the
following the next one
the perimeter is submodular so what does
it mean
that if you take a and b
subsets of rd
then
you can
compute
the perimeter of the union
and the perimeter of the intersection
and that thing is
smaller than
the perimeter of the sum of the sum of
the perimeters
and this is essentially i would say that
the property that allows you to call
something a perimeter
and once you have this property you have
a functional that is submodular for sets
you can introduce a functional then i'm
going to call tv sub epsilon for
functions
and i'm just going to define it by well
you we already define perimeter
for sets so i'm going to take the sub
level sets of of the function u and i'm
going to integrate over uh
all possible sub-level sets and i'm
going to get this functional tv
epsilon
okay
then
what turns out is that this tv
functional
is and this polos from the submodularity
is convex
one homogeneous
uh and
uh lower semi-continuous
with respect to
appropriate topology i'm not going to
discuss technicalities today
at least what is important about this
topology at least what is important for
this lower summit continuity is to be
able to show that there is solutions etc
etc
um
consequence of what i just said though
is the following that the adversarial
training problem
is
or better yet that the problem
um
you know minimize
over f's that go from rd
into the intervals here one so now we're
looking at a relaxation
so before we were looking at a problem
where it says now we're relaxing the
problem
so uh if we do
expectation x comma y
distributed according to mu
of a of f of x minus y
plus
epsilon times t v epsilon f
this problem is an exact convex
relaxation of the adversarial learning
problem so we started with an adversary
learning problem and what we're saying
is that now we can relax it to a convex
problem and the reason why this is a an
exact convex relaxation is because
there is essentially there is something
called the layer kick theorem that
allows you to say that when you have a
solution to this problem over here you
can always find a sub sub level that
also solves the problem the one that you
were you were thinking about
and yes you had a question
no no you use uh use a scalar function
use color
so then what we have is we have this
exact convex relaxation of adversarial
learning
uh how does the tv look like well it has
this form over here so you give me a
function u
and essentially you're integrating with
respect to row one row zero and you are
computing uh differences so this is like
a finite difference if you like but
instead of like taking averages of
finite differences you're taking u x and
then and the minimum you're taking the
ux and the supremum and this is what
what you get and you can check directly
that this function over here is a convex
function etc etc
there's one observation here that is
important is that this tv epsilon
depends on the full distribution move
this is a little bit
uh
contrary to what typically people would
do which is the regularization does not
depend on the full data distribution if
anything maybe about the distribution or
next but not on y and here we see the
rows here and the row one showing up
explicitly
and at the same time this this idea
backs that uh the this uh
what people someday
some
some people do these days which is to
consider data-driven regularization okay
so people use the data to inform what is
the regular i said well at least in this
simple setting we can we can see that
this is not so crazy to consider right
it's not just for algorithmic purposes
we can also see this coming up from the
data
um i just wanted to mention that this is
connected to
a model uh using image analysis to uh
basically do the noising
when you have a fine pattern so these
types of total variations like the ones
that i mentioned earlier allows you to
for example denoise an image like this
and still maintain the finest structure
of the fingerprint in this case this is
what people have done
in image analysis
and if anything for me maybe just to
conclude since i'm running out of time
the equivalent version of that picture
that i presented earlier
for machine learning would be the
following so uh you know so if you have
a situation like this one where you have
these two nicely separated data sets and
then you say okay but is this
nice
set that has like very nice local
perimeter like as small as it can get
is this robust enough for
adversarial attacks and then the idea is
well uh you can see that if you add
perturbations you may have regions when
you are making mistakes essentially and
a better answer would be uh
a curve like the one that is illustrated
there
and if you think about the perimeter the
epsilon perimeter of the red line versus
the flat line the red line actually has
a smaller
epsilon perimeter so it's better
at least it avoids uh this this
misclassifications
uh all right so i think i'm running out
of time i wanted to also mention
something about how is this connected to
graph based learning how can you recover
some of the regularizations that people
using graphics learning from adversarial
learning but since i'm running out of
time i think this is a good place to
start thank you for your attention yeah
thank you nicholas
[Applause]
questions
thank you
um so
i'm not sure i this is very interesting
talk thank you and let me know if this
question makes sense or not but is this
type of result could this shed light on
for example
getting back to the theme of the
workshop
where you could draw samples optimal
places to draw samples from in order to
improve
the closeness of the
minimizer for the l epsilon problem to
the actual problem
um
yeah so could you know for example maybe
maybe you can draw a few more samples
and label them and could this tell you
what regions you should draw those
samples from in order to improve your
problem
uh i mean i think that's a great
question i i'm not sure directly you
know how uh kind of like this this
formulation as a tv plus fidelity can
help in in doing that but um
uh
but i think it's an interesting question
that's as much as i can say um
yeah i mean i should just say one thing
and he said
i mean
in essence like the the the functional
itself is the same right i mean if you
even take a set and you compute this
adversarial thing and you compute this
uh l1 plus tv thing those two things are
the same but what we're gaining is the
structure is the fact that you know we
have some understanding as to what is
happening is this the idea that this
functionality is convex is the idea that
so it is in the structure that perhaps
one can say something not necessarily
for the problem you're asking but in
general
as of right now of course the interest
is mostly theoretical i would say
but
but i i believe that if there is any
hope to use this for something more
practical then it will be in trying to
exploit the specific structure that is
revealed
that that's where maybe there's could
some advantages could arise yeah
uh so this perspective seems pretty
similar to the one taken in geometric
measure theories just out of pure
curiosity um is there some kind of like
interpretation for what a iso-perimetric
problem would look like for for this
definition of perimeter uh
well so i know that uh so this so for
example this um
um
uh
right so first of all so isoparametric
browse for non-local problems like i
mean i don't know for specifically for
this one but people have to my knowledge
do they have considered stuff like that
like as a parametric inequalities for
non-local perimeters i'm not sure if
it's specifically for this one uh
there's another thing one thing that i
should say about this specific perimeter
and is that it's not it's not symmetric
so for example the perimeter of a is not
the same as a complement that has to do
with row zero being different from row
one
so i'm not sure if for this specific uh
perimeter
uh you know how how would that
isoparametric inequality look like
that's as much as i can say
thank you
so let's thank uh
well